one thing that came out on my podcast
with him because i asked him there's
this misconception that like
that old people or people with that were
poor lost money at my firm
it just wasn't true like it was not true
like i ran the firm and like this was a
policy in place like
we only call rich people now it's a was
on purpose i didn't want
people that couldn't afford to lose to
lose but also
because i'm a greedy bastard like hey
you know what you know you're going to
go take money buy so
take it from those who have the most
because you're going to get the most so
i'm not trying to say i
was the greatest guy ever but i
certainly purposely steer the weir
stand clear of people that could not
afford to lose money right
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is
an entrepreneur a motivational speaker
a best-selling author and the original
wolf of wall street
jordan belfort finally welcome to the
reuben report how are you i'm
glad to be here i am good
well i thought you'd be a perfect guy to
have on this week because we are both
in this crazy town of los angeles
i've i've been to your house it ain't
bad my friend you've got you're in your
beautiful
studio and you've got a pretty swank
setup but tomorrow
gavin newsom is going to allow us to
leave our homes can you believe it's
actually happening
you know let me give you my take on it i
don't think anybody really listened to
him
i don't think there was any lockdown
that i noticed other than that i feel
terrible for restaurant owners who were
forced for
no good reason at least in my opinion to
close their outdoor dining after they
spent tons of money putting in the
safeguards that
one would need to have outdoor dining
and all the
barriers petitions tears i mean it's
crazy and then
just i mean i really feel bad but i i
have to say other than that
i think that there was like corona
fatigue here
in la and it was more of a ceremonial
lockdown i remember the first lockdown
davey there was no one on the street
there was no cars around this was not
that over the last four weeks he was
like oh let's screw over all the
restaurant owners and just like wipe
them out of business that's kind of what
it felt like to me how about you
yeah i mean i think well my audience
knows i mean we've basically been
ignoring it around here and i feel bad
for the small business owners and
and the restaurant tours and you know
it's sad when i'm in your neighborhood
or even in my neighborhood where you
drive by the main drags and you know
everything
everything's closed but that's kind of a
that's kind of a good spot
for us to start because for the for the
people that
know you they they know leo the leo
dicaprio version of you
um but in a way you're you're kind of a
startup guy you're like
you're gritty and you get out there and
you do stuff that's what your whole
career the ups and the downs has been
about how if you
right now were just trying to start up
something
um how would you feel in the midst of
knowing that the government can just
come in
and and shut you down at any point i
feel like at this point
you have to to take advantage of that
insane fact
that the government can come in and shut
down
many different types of commerce right
now so what you want to do is position
yourself
in a in an industry or business that
would give you the greatest likelihood
of being insulated from any of those
shutdowns so
things that are you know delivered
online and
can be done from a home and get
delivered through the mail
those are the sort of things right now
that everyone is focusing on things that
are
you know virtualizing basically
everything so i think
you know i hate to say this but it's
true like in the worst of times
you typically have the most opportunity
for people who are willing to go out
there and take
risks so like if i look at my business
and i had this conversation with someone
just last night about you know that
there's a new round of ppp loans coming
out and i
i apply for it and i deserve to get it
my business got
decimated decimated my speaking business
because that was my core business but
now i'm doing well because i have a new
business there's
but the point is is like if you what
business you were in last year you have
to say okay
well in the new reality the new normal
if you want to call it
those rules you know you can't just go
out there and do business the way you
used to do it i have people working in
my house i don't have an
office i focus on online delivery on
virtual learning on
other things i know that won't be as
impacted so i think that you
you have to go out there right now and
assume
that at any given moment the wrong can
be pulled
out from under your feet and while when
we were growing up we used to call like
oh let's go into defensive industries
like
like food and like everyone needs to eat
right like the movies everyone goes
those are like defensive industries
right well now defensive industries are
characterized as things that are
defensive that can't be
shut down by draconian state and
government measures it's insane
so do you think that's kind of the key
to being a good business person
a good a good business guy in general
someone who can like just see that
things have changed like i think a lot
of people
right now they still think that the old
world's coming back they still think
february 2020 is coming back but
february 2021 is going to be way
different
than february 2020 and i don't think
february 2020 comes back
i think this is one thing that's that's
um that's
always constant in this world and that
is that the world is always changing the
difference right now and i
think you're a hundred percent right i
don't think things are going back to the
way they were
ever i really don't um and
not that people won't have you know i
think people will not always wear masks
and i think that
there won't always be people social
distancing because you know if you look
back right now in the middle of bubbles
with things like bitcoin and all this
crazy stuff going on
with some real estate prices soaring in
certain areas
and you look back in 2008 and we didn't
learn anything
it's the same thing again another bubble
yeah so people like you know
it's really bad after 2008 in 2000 i was
like oh
like we got to be really careful we
can't have bubbles and people forget
really quickly
but i think you're right though that
like i think that
there's a new way that people have
become accustomed to consuming
everything whether it's food movies
learning buying products i think that
people have gotten
comfortable right now or used to and
even prefer in some
respects to buy things and stay home and
i think that's never going to change i
think that's going to be here to stay
there's a movie some crazy movie that
was that was i think bruce willis was
in this movie where they oh call what
was it called where they're like they
all live
virtual lives they're like actually
locked away in these like little shells
there
have like their counterparts like their
their clones go out there
and move through the world because it's
too dangerous and too deadly with
viruses and diseases
i can't wait it's a really interesting
move but it's almost like what we're
heading towards i feel like
yeah i'm shocked i don't know what that
is but it's got it's got a bit of the
matrix in there for sure right
like we're just we're just the batteries
for the digital world in essence
basically yeah i i think that one you
know one of the things you brought was a
very good point is that
you know what makes a great business
person it's not just seeing it's also
the ability to pivot quickly it's
pivoting and learning how to be wrong
quickly too you have to learn how to try
things
and be wrong and live to fight another
day
not to get so emotionally involved in
the things that you're trying where you
feel like
i got to make it work it's like you know
i went this far you know no this is a
bad idea and like you know
you try it doesn't work next and really
to not get caught up in bad
ideas not to go down rabbit holes and
also just to keep trying and trying and
trying and again
until you find that model i think if you
do that right now
there is a path to success for everybody
out there no matter how
desperate things might seem right now so
that right there is what i want to spend
most of our time
talking about because that's that's your
expertise and you've you've it's not
something you're just talking about
you've
you've freaking lived it but but i live
again again
but one thing before we get to that
since since we are both in l.a
right now my audience knows like you
know i went to florida a couple weeks
ago i was happy
man it was open and good people were
smiling
like there was some great energy there
and everything else are you worried
about the future
of la not only because of newsome and
lockdowns and all that but
the progressive mayor garcetti here and
just generally the amount of homeless
and drugs and
the whole freaking thing yeah i'm out of
here i'm i'm getting out of here uh uh
oh you are oh great yeah yeah you're
you're on my short list of like four
friends left now
i gotta go yeah you know i might keep i
might keep a
small apartment here at some point i
mean i i i can't you know listen
california was the place that everybody
else
dreamed of moving to it's this and the
weather is beautiful
the terrain is beautiful the air is
mostly clear at least
where we are right and um but you know i
think you know
really poor political policies have
turned it into a freaking cesspool
not only that been to a high tax
cesspool
and i don't care paying i'm okay to pay
taxes if they're gonna use those taxes
for for great things but they're not you
know they use the taxes
they're wasted um and i just i can't
it's just it's honestly beyond the pale
what's happening here
and i think the only solace i could take
is i think it's worse than san francisco
so like i mean i i think it's actually
worse there right so oh well it's not as
bad there yet
right so um i plan on moving to florida
um and was but you know what's bob he's
like it's causing a bubble right now
everyone's running to florida
driving up real estate prices i'm kind
of waiting like you know
i don't know but like again it's this
weird thing here where you and i are
watching
we're almost like sitting here and
watching in real time the decline
and unraveling of of once great
city it's insane to watch yeah and
what's also weird about it and i think
this exact same thing happened in san
francisco was it doesn't happen
overnight it takes a couple years but
ev if you talk to literally everybody
anyone that will talk to you
they all admit it's going in the wrong
direction yet for some reason people in
la they can't make the connection
between voting for policies
and and these politicians and then the
bad stuff that happens there's like a
complete disconnect there
because i i think what happens is that
you know
um and i want to i don't want to get to
left right here yeah because
but i think that what the democrats have
been very very clever and very adept
at at his hearts and minds campaign
of of using this sort of they've linked
these things with some there's some
moral high ground
that they have with things like climate
and and gay rights and other things that
are completely
unlinked to the economy and yet you know
it becomes an emotional issue
and people when they go to the voting
booth often vote based on emotion
and not based on logic and they've been
really really clever they they've
consolidated this party which comes to
represent
things that like i think most people
don't agree with
fiscally but they they have this
overwhelming and i think the republicans
on the
made some huge errors like this the gay
rights i mean that good lord i mean
stop already i mean we just stop like
like
just accept it no one is so stupid so if
the republicans hopefully will wake up
and see what's going on right now like
you know they need to
and they've come a long way i believe i
don't want to get caught up in the
election and stuff but
i i think that it's time for
for that the republican party to be what
it should be
which is the most inclusive party for
everybody
um that cares about less government more
rights for people and
you know not screwing around with
everybody's life and i understand
somehow that
and both cars always get hijacked by the
extremists on either side
but what happens is the extremists on
the left have this moral
high ground so to speak and they're
using that to win the hearts and minds
of young people
and the academics and the high-tech
you know mafia there whatever you want
to call it and it's causing elections to
be swayed in one way and it's
basically taken this once great city and
it's you know essentially flushed it
literally down the drain all right well
look if if you buy a couple acres in
florida maybe just clear out some land
for me and i'll
buy the gator patch like hey dave come
on
don't worry they don't bite they're not
crocs they're alligators
big difference yeah yeah big difference
big difference all right so
let's talk about that other stuff though
let's talk about the stuff that you
really
it's your area of expertise first off
i'm sure that everyone watching this has
seen
wolf of wall street but for the people
that that aren't sure who
jordan belfort is give me the the minute
elevator pitch
on uh what yeah on what you've done
so you know when i was very young we
grew up in long island both of us right
i um
started a firm uh in the late 80s
um and i uncovered this niche in the
market for selling five dollar stocks to
the richest americans no one had tried
it before and i
then very shortly thereafter discovered
a way of training
sales people so i could take average
people that really weren't great at
selling
sales and make them unbelievable at
sales those two things combined resulted
in me building
what became very quickly the largest
firm in the country
back when i was still in my early to mid
20s and i was making a million bucks a
week
and i was from a poor family and i
absolutely went hog wild and lived out
every
adolescent fantasy i could ever have
dreamed of from
you know buying a white ferrari test
roaster because don johnson had one of
miami vice
from taking the private jet out to la
and renting out the presidential
the beverly wilshire because richard
gere had done it in pretty woman
i went oh i went full on there and
ultimately it started off as a beautiful
amazing thing and i lost my way and
i started manipulating some stocks
smuggled my switzerland
clients lost money i went to jail and i
wrote a book
about it and that book became a movie
and i got really lucky because when you
make a movie there's two things you can
have that can happen
you could like have a movie made about
you and and i love danny devito but
let's just say you can get played by
danny
no offense no offense no if i loved
anybody but or
leonardo dicaprio and have martin
scorsese direct that movie and i have to
say
you know what they did is they they took
a book that i worked very hard on and i
was proud of but they
uh and the writer terence winter is a
brilliant guy
and um and all of us together
created what really ended up being a
very special amazing movie that
has certainly stood the test of time and
become
probably one of the biggest cult hits of
all time and and i think it will
i i don't see it ending i think it's
just here to stay forever because it
really came out
no people yeah and and it's awesome
who could what can you say right it's
just perfect i mean the movie really
from start to finish
is is just perfect the speech that leo
that you give i mean is just
absolutely epic and has been memed into
a million other things
but you you mentioned you mentioned were
that we're both from long island you're
you're about i
you were born in 62 right am i allowed
to say that right am i allowed to say
that so yeah
so you you guys you got four you look
pretty good considering
all the drugs i've consumed right i mean
good lord i should be like keith
richards from the rolling stones but i
you know thank god i did pretty well you
know no no i can't see through your skin
you're doing all right um
but no you're you got 14 years on me but
we basically come
from virtually the same town and a lot
of the guys that are in
the movie that you train in effect are
are from syosset they're from plainview
it's a lot of these
these local long island towns you know
right outside new york city and we
talked about this when i was on your
show but i'm sort of fascinated by it
it there is something about long island
that has generated
so many talented people
corrupt people comedians actors money
guys
like it's nuts i was going to say
you know as you would i don't want
there's something in the water like even
in my apartment building
on my floor i lived in this six story
low rent apartment building three
people on my floor went out to wall
street and built
massive firms now one of them besides he
was a good friend so he worked but
another was an independent guy named
randy pace who i
babysat for his kids he's 10 years he
passed away now
he had one of the largest firms on wall
street in the 70s like so it's like
there's something it's it's and and the
sciosci
it's like the siosit jericho
thing i was like bayside like it's and
i'll tell you what i think it is i'll
tell you what i think it is
i think it is a combination
of proximity to massive wealth
but not actually having massive wealth
it's about not being so poor that it
seems out of reach
it's about having a great education so
it creates this almost aspiration like
you almost
feel like it's just there it's within
your reach you see it it's not yours
you have you're given the tools because
like i think what's really sad sometimes
is some really you know kids that grew
up with these in
bad areas they're really they have the
decks stacked against them like they
don't get a great education
um they have a lot of gang violence like
things it's almost like they have to
really be special to make it out and
that hopefully it will continue to
change and get better
but i think we didn't have that like we
although we were i wasn't born rich
i this shot that something bad had to
happen for me not to get out to the next
level like there was such a
a pathway out and i think part of it is
that
stressing education for sure was just a
big thing in my area
and also there was like this mythical
thing like you go that you move out to
long island you get rich like that that
was a path
and i think that's part of it you know
and i think that that that
if you take those things and it creates
a sort of competition and
pathway to success that's my opinion so
so when you were
when you were building the companies and
you figured out how you could do this by
sort of reaching the rich people with
something that wasn't normally thought
of
as kind of in their world what what kind
of like ethical
issues were were you having as you were
doing it like at first did you think it
was fully legit
and then kind of lost control or did you
kind of know or did you not know or like
what
were you struggling with very good
question so number one
there's there's two things and there's a
very interesting fact that came out
on my podcast i had the fbi agent who
indicted me is a friend of mine now
wonderful guy oh man i all right i got a
little
yeah you should have him on your podcast
he's a great guy yeah and and
one thing that came out on my podcast
with him because i
asked him there's this misconception
that like that old people or people
that were poor lost money at my firm it
just wasn't true like it was not true
like
i ran the firm and like this was a
policy in place like
we only call rich people now it's a was
on purpose i didn't want
people that couldn't afford to lose to
lose but also
because i'm a greedy bastard like hey
you know what you know if you're gonna
go take money buy something
take it from those who have the most
because you're gonna get the most so i'm
not trying to say i
was the greatest guy ever but i
certainly purposely steer the weir
stand clear of people that could not
afford to lose money right
but yet the perception was that people
that couldn't afford
lost money the fbi agent clarified
because what happened was i left the
firm i
sold the firm in 95 and after that and
before
that it was very controlled and we were
basically
i wouldn't listen it wasn't like
stealing it wasn't it started off
perfectly legit
and then it started to spiral out of
control but it was very contained
about 95 legit i would say now that
given what i see on wall street what i
did was 100 legitimate
like and now given what i see happening
every single day
i i used to always say i deserve to go
to jail now i don't really think so
anymore because
there's such corruption on wall street
it's like so bad now
i really you know i say well okay well i
did things wrong but it's not nearly i
didn't
bankrupt greece or isolate at least so i
you know i'm not that bad a guy right
so no seriously the things that you see
now happening in maine
in the bigger firms is unbelievable but
the the big
mistake i made was this lapse of ethics
one step at a time so i want to be clear
i did break the law
i deserve to go to jail for breaking the
law although my my
perspective's changed is what i see is
comparably but it's still like i don't
want to
say i didn't i did break the law it
started off perfectly legitimate
trying to make people money and then i
made some fundamental errors and i
allowed the firm to grow too fast and i
lost
control of it and then the first time i
really broke the laws like up i'll i'll
do it once i'll never do it again
but then my line of morality got moved a
bit
so next time you know you do things good
again then next time you step over it's
a little bit further to the right
and then back again before you know it
through these tiny almost
imperceptible steps you're doing things
you thought you'd never do
you're associated with people you never
thought you'd associate with and it
all seems perfectly okay it's like you
dip your toe into a bathtub piping hot
water like oh wow
so hot right and then three minutes
later you're in the water and it feels
fine now when i was a young boy i
remember distinguishing oh i know what's
going on
i get in the bath and i'm the water's
cooling down because my body's cool
but no the water's not cooling down
you're just getting used to it
yeah and that was the mistake i made and
it's a mistake i'm very aware of today
like
i won't even take one little step
over the ethical line like i am real i'm
more careful than anybody else
because i can't afford to have a second
hiccup here right
so i i always say to myself like any
action i take
like if it's even the slightest bit i
think i just won't do it
i'm not gonna take that chance that's my
best protection against ever doing
anything wrong again
and i think it's really good for
everyone to look that way but there are
some things in life where there's gray
areas and
there's nothing wrong with playing in
the gray you know what i'm saying but
you know i think that the test is if
you're going to hurt someone else
along the way that's probably the the
single thing that that's like
if you're gonna hurt someone else if
it's a victimless in the gray okay well
you can consider it but
other than that it's a no-go well i just
love the honesty there because i think a
lot of people think it's like oh there
there are like good people and then one
day they just make a decision
to like do bad things where it's like oh
along the way of building something that
that started just
exploding under you like some strange
decision not strange some some decisions
start being made and then next thing you
know you're in
you're in that different water but one
of the things i watched the movie about
two weeks ago
in preparation for this and i've seen it
probably 10 times already but one of the
things that i think is like your
greatest
skill and i sense probably what you get
the most joy from
is the way you were able to train these
guys just guys
guys that weren't thinking that they
were going to be selling stocks guys
that probably didn't have much of a
future
guys that were doing all kinds of drugs
and had all kinds of other problems
but that you could turn them into
something that they weren't is is pretty
cool
it still might to this day it's
definitely like the passion i have
and i love the fact that i go out and
get to do that not as much now with
cover but you know i still do it
virtually and i'm sure that part will
eventually come back
of speaking to live and you know these
huge stadiums and stuff which i used to
do a lot of
um i i you know what i really think and
i noticed is very young when i was my
early 20s and i had this ability to
to you know kind of motivate and just
naturally knew what someone wanted to
hear and i really
perfected that over many many years but
i think what i
the most important thing to take away
for everyone listening is that
i don't think that you the listener just
i don't know who you all are but
what you're truly capable of people tend
to not realize
what they're truly capable of like we
all have all this really bad
programming and so much of it
comes down to you not possessing the
skills that you need there are certain
core skills that you need to succeed in
this world and they're not all taught
most aren't taught many of us are
naturally good at certain things but we
don't realize is that like for example
okay
you want to play tennis and you suck so
what do you do
you take tennis lessons like you go and
get lessons
right you know well if you want to go
out and succeed in the world of business
and make money what do you do get
lessons like it's so i like
people fail to make this connection that
like you know all of these things
especially now where every bit of
information is so at your fingertips
pretty much everything that you need can
be
learned what can be found and if you're
struggling right now making money or
finding a career or just feeling like
you're living in a power life
it's not because you are fundamentally
flawed or inferior or not worth it it's
because
you probably lack some specific
knowledge that you need to have
in order to realize your dreams and your
hopes and all the things that
would just make you feel like life is
just awesome and
it's all out there and i think it's so
freaking sad
that people are like they get blocked
from going out there and
living the life they deserve because
they lack knowledge it's like
knowledge i mean that's the thing it's
not yeah this talent i'm never going to
be roger federer on the tennis court
but i could get good enough to have a
lot of fun and and and win a lot of
games from some good plays like
like you're never going to be me as a
sales person but i could teach you to be
so good at it that like
you'll get whatever you want in life and
with and it's not just sales it could be
how do you run a business it's all out
there
the templates the work has been done by
people granted it's
the promise a lot of charlatans out
there teaching stuff as well but you
could kind of you know
you can look at reviews and search
around but
i would urge everybody here like i don't
care you know if times are tough right
now or
you feel like there's just like you
don't know which way to turn like
you have the ability to do whatever you
want in life you just do
as long as you want to take the time to
learn the things you have to learn and
take some risks
yeah and now you can learn so much of it
for free too it's like youtube
this a lot of this stuff is free it's
free yeah i mean i know people are
paying you a lot of money to go to your
seminars but like
at the same time people pay me every
single day and they buy my courses
and you know what you can you could go
online
go to my own website and get a lot
enough
for free the difference is is that of
course
if you pay it's all perfectly laid out
for you
it's the next level but i purposely give
i want people
if you can't afford it just go and get
the stuff for free from me because once
they do
they they'll buy because they'll say oh
well it's great but i'd rather have it
all laid out for me in exactly the right
order and and we will you know just it's
a better deal for them
but you can get everything for free if
so it's not money
and everyone has enough time when it
comes down to what happens is
people they get caught up in like
these limiting beliefs with
self-defeating attitudes and
negative programs they start thinking
that you know this is my lot in life
and i'm stuck and you know maybe it
works for this guy or that guy or jordan
or dave but i'm not
them it's not and and it's so sad i
think now if there's any
ever been a time where you can reinvent
yourself now is the time
the whole world is like the whole world
is going online
everyone is is just you know is in that
same boat of like you know
like what's next what there's money
always to be made in those situations
yeah i i totally agree it's like we're
watching the old world go away but there
is a new world on the horizon and and
there's going to be a lot of people that
build a lot of cool stuff and make a lot
of money in that process
last night i went a friend of mine had
some surgery and i was at his house and
he's telling me about bitcoin and
gamestop and all these things and i'm i
was really ragging
on this new world of like a lot of the
some of the way money is being made
right now but i think he missed my miss
my message
like my point was is that like i don't
like i don't play myself in some of
these things that i think are
or like you know it could go one way or
the other i'm more of a skills based
player like i just like things that are
more skills-based where i could stack
the deck in my favor by being really
great
at something you know versus like when i
look at like throwing the dart and
hoping i catch it going up versus going
down right yeah so like my friend's like
oh you're so negative on the new world
and i agree i'm not i'm positive i think
that you're 100
right the old world as we knew it
is basically either i wouldn't say it's
dead but it's dying a very rapid death
and there's this
new like entity forming right before our
eyes of how people go about and
consume and do and live everything and
everywhere
and opportunity is all around us right
now and as long as you're willing to
accept the fact that you're right that
it's not going to be february 20 20 in
another month right now it's going to be
2021
and the lockdowns will end eventually
and you know what there will be
opportunity i believe that's going to be
extraordinary it's also going to be some
hell to pay
for all the fiscal responsibility but
that's a separate issue
yeah so this is an odd odd segue from
the success part but as you were doing
all of this stuff and and the money and
the traveling of
all the crazy stuff you're doing you
were you were on a lot of drugs
i mean the movie is sort of like a
an adventure an adventure through drugs
in retrospect are you like shocked that
you were even able to survive
and there were some moments where maybe
you wouldn't have shocked
at this point i think it's an amazing
testament to
the resilience of the human body like
the human liver
um one thing i had going for me is i
wasn't a big drinker
and i think that like what happens with
a lot of the drugs that i
took and i got plain lucky like better
men than me have taken one hot dose and
they've died like heath ledger and
a lot of great people right i got lucky
no doubt about it but
i wasn't a drinker and i think what
happens with alcohol is it sort of takes
a different
it takes drugs that you might know what
the safe doses are for you
and it throws it out the window it
intensifies the effect of lots of drugs
and it depresses breathing and and your
heart
beat and i think i was pretty at least
um aware enough that i never got myself
i mean i overdosed
once um but that was pretty much on
purpose it was more of an out you know a
cro
outcry of an act more than trying to
kill myself but i mean i i think i got
very lucky because at the end of the day
um i look at many people who i
went through that they never really
recovered fully
they never really you know if they're
around now they look unhealthy
some of them died um but
um i i i also by the grace of god by the
way as well i mean you know
you got to thank i think that i i've
never been i believe in god but i i
think that at this point certainly
there's definitely a path for me that
wasn't
supposed to end back then and i've been
sober
for a really long time like i'd still
drink a little bit but i you know
i haven't done drugs it's been a very
very
the last time i really partied like hard
was april 17
1997. that was my date where i went to
a.a and
and you know and that was it and then
i've you know i've dabbled a couple of
times since then but never
i've never done drugs like you know
anything more than a little bit i tried
smoking pot a few times
but that's it yeah yeah but a lot of the
guys a lot of the guys though
they they either didn't make it or they
or they're pretty bad people yeah it's
pretty
you know terrible but i think uh also my
drug
choice was mostly like i was quail using
cocaine
it wasn't heroin you know and heroin is
like more of like you know
the death blow because of the it
depresses your breathing
choking on your own vomit stuff like
that like i think the drugs that i did
were more
not safer i was like oh they're safe
drugs i think they're less
bad you know they're less bad so to
speak you know
on the terrible like on the terrible
index they're not quite as terrible you
know
right exactly um all right that's good
to know though that your children out
there yeah you do still drink
occasionally though so
yeah i love a nice little glass of wine
here and there i've never drank i never
drink enough to get really drunk or ever
it's not my thing
yeah so what what right now are you
seeing sort of business-wise with all
with all the chaos and with the dinner
that you had with your friend last night
and everyone's sort of hot on bitcoin
right now
and there's there's suddenly a whole
bunch of you know social media
alternatives i think you know a little
bit about what i'm doing with locals.com
there's like a whole bunch of stuff sort
of appearing
are there things that are really
interesting you right now yeah so
you know i have my own you know my own
business which is doing really well i'm
growing it right now which is a you know
a recruiting business that i'm rolling
out over you know around the world right
now where i
help companies scale by finding them
sales people so
that's my long-term you know
outcome that i see i i think a lot of
the things that you know
like these bitcoin and trading you know
listen there's windows of opportunity
for everything
i what scares me always scares me about
bitcoin
is that you know i as much as i know
about the government
and how they detest money laundering i
just
i just scratched my head and say how
would they allow this
to become something that could so
easily be used to launder money and it
can
i don't care i listen i have a lot of
friends that are really successful
that love bitcoin and i have some that
hate bitcoin and the ones that love
bitcoin they're legitimate people
and they're not scamming they just like
they like it they have their reasons why
um but it just it's i know enough about
it's very easy to use bitcoin to like
hide money and
you know and do deals that are that
could that would otherwise be much more
difficult to do
uh through the traditional banking
system so my point is like i
i just question i'm not saying that's
what bitcoin is only used for because
it's not
but why would the government's my fear
it's like the government said you know
we spent all this time trying to stamp
out switzerland
and the caymans so what all right well
great let's just get turn control over
now
to a system that we can't control i it
doesn't make sense to me the only thing
that does make sense
to me is if it's the government itself
that released bitcoin and they know
everything like
it was actually the cia or the
government that's behind the whole thing
and like yeah go hide your money that's
great and then like they know where
everything is
that if that came out i'd say aha now it
all makes sense you know now you're now
you're really going down the rabbit hole
other than that
but other than that other than that i lo
i think the technology itself of
blockchain
is really elegant i think it's got a lot
of uses and i think that
i understand that bitcoin is a lot of
people that like it
that and the more people there's a
network effect on that in terms of not
so much for
spending it but the network effect of
the more people that think it's worth
something i guess it really is in some
respect and then
also that we always look at things from
a purview of the united states and it's
having a stable currency
so you know imagine if you're in a
country or let's say you're in uh
peru or somewhere or chile or uh in that
country and the
the currency is the valuing or cuba and
it's
almost impossible to have us uh to be
able to hold currency because that's not
worth it they would usually use dollars
but bitcoin is a good old i guess it's
an alternative it's not very good for
transactions
it's a storehouse of value i guess it's
much better than their own
their own basically worthless currency
so i think there's applications for
other countries that we
probably don't realize as much coming
from the united states i've seen it as
they go around the world that
that people in other countries they're
much more thick it's like oh yeah it's
you know
better than my own currency i'll take
that any day so we'll see the jury's out
i i um i'm still
ambivalent i think that there it could
go either way right now if the us
government doesn't step in
and try to squash it i think it could go
much higher
do you think despite the opportunity
that we have right now because of
because of the chaos um that just sort
of generally the biden administration
with taxes and regulation all that stuff
is is going to scare a lot of people
from from building the right businesses
what i think is that
typically a president
inherits what they got from the
administration before them
so biden will reap the rewards of
trumpism and that will probably last for
the first year or so
maybe two and then the effects of
bidenis and whatever that might be and
the liberal policies
will start to really take hold more in
the
second and third year and even fourth
year of his term so i think this is
really weird
i think like you know administrations
you know you know they either get the
credit or blame for things that really
probably weren't
much of their own doing um and my
biggest
thing is immigration i i don't get it i
just don't understand i don't understand
um i there's no doubt the immigration
system is broken i have clients who are
immigration lawyers and so i really have
a very good insight into immigration
right now
really good insight uh so i understand
the system it's terrible it's broken it
needs to change
there's a lot of terrible things
happening to illegal aliens that
shouldn't be happening
that you probably would i couldn't
believe it until i actually saw it
myself that
there are things that it wasn't like
trump's fault it's been happening
for a long time you know it has started
until obama it got worse under trump
um but to let's say
everyone can stay it's insane it's it's
like
it's pissing in the eye of every person
that legally came here as much as
for giving student loans is pissing in
the eye of every person
who went to school borrow money and paid
it back it's like there's like
this moral hazard here in this thing and
so you know obviously
the the intelligent person would say if
i'm gonna make no consequence for
sneaking in everyone's gonna come and
sneak in
if i make no consequence for not paying
back student loans no one's gonna pay
back their loans
so there's a huge issue with these
things and i think that's i think that
the common theme that you and i think
agree on is that like about just
personal responsibility
for one's actions and i think that's
like almost the underlying theme on
on the left is like there's almost a
lack of personal responsibility for
one's actions
and where one is in life at this moment
where where does just common sense fall
into that because it's interesting when
i listen to you it's like i
i know you can go deep on all all the
business stuff and and how to help
people succeed and all that
but you just strike me actually more as
just like a common sense guy
more than anything in a way and that may
be a long island thing too at some level
or like a queen's thing
i think that i think that
i think common sense is much more
easily shown when one isn't
saddled with prejudices like i
like i don't care about any of the
social stuff
on either side i just don't like to me
i think people should just do and be
what they want
and have like i i think a lot of the
problems with the
with these both parties is they
represent
things that are so like they're not like
there's politics and there's other
things you know what i'm trying to say
and like
like for me i think i see things really
clearly because like
i don't like i don't care like i would
say i'm prejudiced against two types of
people
lazy people and stupid people other than
that i love or hate everybody else
equally right like
i think a lot i think there still is out
there there's a lot of prejudice people
have a lot of like um
just a lot of like they come into the
into the into an idea with like not
looking at it from a level playing field
and i think what i'm what i think one
thing i do pretty well
is i'm able to look at i'm able to take
a step back and go like it's called
going better on my own
i just take a step back okay and all in
truth all things being equal like let's
take the [ __ ] out of this thing
what's the real truth here like i think
i have a pretty decent
read i guess everyone probably thinks
that
right no i really think i have a pretty
good read
you know i'm i'm well educated i i i i
make sure i listen to a lot of different
points of view
so i think that if i sound reasonable
it's of course i'm not
allowing a belief i have about some a
core belief i have
whether it's about abortion or or
or being gay or this it's like to me
it's so stupid
like to allow that to color your your
judgment
for other decisions but it does i think
it does all the time and it's really
destructive to uh to the country and to
the world i really think it is
how much of that do you think is
connected you just mentioned that you
believe in god i've been
saying for the last couple months that
i'm probably more of a believer now
than at any time in my adult life for
sure
and i think it's partly that i've
watched so many people
from like a purely secular perspective
or an atheist perspective
that just like they can change their
opinions on anything on any given day
depending on who said what or if trump
said something you say the opposite
something like that
where where people that have some belief
we can all argue what that definition of
god is it just
keeps you at least some level censored
uh centered i think that
you know like i don't look at it like
there's a big man in the sky in a chair
like abraham lincoln sitting against god
like i
i think this is like i don't think is it
i think that there's like
i think that when you really come down
to it like god and science is very all
very close like i think they're all on
two sides of the same coin
some people call it one thing others
called something else um
but i just think that like i'm not the
highest authority out there myself i
think there's some i think that there is
truth
i think there's there's like truth i
think there's goodness
and there's badness there's right
there's wrong i think it's pretty
obvious
and i think like those things are just
you know
where they come from i don't know i just
when i say believe in god i mean i i
believe there's something
out there greater than myself and i
don't really care what it
is i think it gets corrupted by religion
by organized religion i mean that's the
biggest problem is that
people it's such a powerful it's such a
powerful
pretense and a powerful thought just a
premise that
it's just so easily corrupted by smart
people for their own
ends and i think religion in an
organized sense
is just that to the extreme very people
that were smart
took some people whether it was jesus or
buddha or
whoever it might be or muhammad had
really amazing
ideas was a whatever they were they were
higher
level of thinker or teacher or spirit
and then
oh i could take that [ __ ] and freaking
make it good you know i go
damn i can get everyone to give money i
can control the population make them
and that's probably the worst view of it
i'm sure there's a lot of benevolent
people in there as well but i think that
at some point a lot of this stuff gets
gets you know goes towards the darker
side because
it's so powerful because it's not it's
such a like i think one of the greatest
movies is like um contact it's with
jodie ford though right
right it's just carl sagan yeah right
it's a great book great movie
and like you know they're like they ask
her do you so you think that 95
of the population is suffering from mass
delusion
right i mean right okay and she says she
says i've answered the question
yeah basically i've answered the
question right i've already asked i
think i've already answered that
question but
the point is is that you know it's a
vowel like you know occam's race like
you know again like everyone it's it
can't all be crazy so
i think that my my biggest fear right
now
you all know my biggest fear dave i'll
tell you what it is my biggest fear is
that we're living
in the midst of a reordering of the
world
as it is in terms of power with between
china and the united states
and i think there's there's the moment
the big
cataclysm is going to be if there is a
shift
away from the u.s dollar to
another currency whether it's the juan
or some other
currency this is going to be that black
swan moment that the
the reason the u.s is allowed to get
away with what they're allowed to get
away with and reason the world is
typically stable is the u.s is that
stable currency that's backed by only
one thing
military might yeah that's all this is
because we have more atom bombs and
smart
and planes and stealth and this and that
that at the end of the day it just comes
down we could blow you up like it's
it really oh it comes down to just
that right right because they they own
all of our debt so it's like if they
call in the chips it's like well
this if the mafia doesn't have a guy
that can beat your guy up you're in
pretty good shape
exactly it's really sad but it's true at
the end of the day it really comes by
societies organize around war powers
it's like about war protecting it's
going to go back to ancient times
so i think right now as you have china
playing this really slow methodical long
game
you know you can't listen you can't be a
consumer
and stay on top forever there's
producers and there's consumers
and you the us has become a
consumer-based economy we make
very little now except ones and zeros
and you know
china now is and by the way china is
also getting to the point now where you
know they
they are now you know as you start to
elevate out of that middle class you
know you become more of a consumer
oriented country we're a financial
services based country
you know so but that can't you know
watch what happens though look where
does the wealth go
where did the reserves go they flow
always to the people who are producing
not consuming
and that's why the us is basically flat
broke right now
and you know it's almost like you know
we talk about too big to fail
with our banks but you know the u.s is
the ultimate the ultimate
example of too big to fail because you
know if the u.s dollar fails well you
know good luck what happens next like
not everything but that's the question
is like how long how
long can you kick the can down the road
and i think there's probably smarter
people than me
economy that really study this stuff
then maybe no i don't really know at
this point but you know
it seems to me that like at a certain
point in time something's got to give
and it's probably gonna have to do with
uh
an event whether it's an emt uh um
um you know um emp
emp event something's gonna happen that
is gonna be impossible to come back
from and that's when we're gonna see a
complete reordering of
everything and how and here's the thing
how hard would that be to happen
an emp like that's not like you know i
always wonder like when is like one of
these crazy rogue
let's just let's reset the board let's
reset the
board i mean they did it they did it in
oceans 12
so or ocean was that ocean's 11 maybe it
was the first one
they did it in like avengers and civil
war they did it they did it like
in in sokovia and the evil guy scovia
did it right exactly
if they've done it if they've done it in
avengers then clearly they can do it but
i i actually
the the broader point though of like
that they own so much of our debt
and that we owe them so much money and
that what ultimately keeps us safe is
just our military so it's like
yeah we end up just kicking everything
down the road until
this it's almost like it has to end
horribly it's not really something you
want to think about but
at some point it's like how does it not
end it's not like you can ever really
pay them back we can't get out of debt
yeah i'll tell you how it ends very
simple look at england
look at england i mean like england's a
perfect example of a post you know
global power that's a declining power
that's you know basically you know
it's not like it's a you know if you
look back i just watched it it just
doesn't richard did you see bridgette
it's pretty good actually i didn't i
know i know a bunch of people
told me but you look back at the wealth
the concentrated
wealth and power that you know this
small island
had right they they ruled the world by
you know it's always about you know
and what really killed britain was you
know the cost of of projecting their
power to the periphery of the empire was
just too great
to hold right u.s is the same situation
right now
and it always comes down to how much
does it cost you to project your power
out
and and i i think that you look at
britain right now and you
what do you see well you still see a big
financial center there in london
you still see lots of wealthy people but
you know it's a lot of middle class
loggery that people like not you know
feeling there's a way out a lot of like
just like a very
just that that that boom it's not that
thing oh yeah
people were on the way up so i don't
think it's like you know the united
states becomes the great dust bowl of of
unless something really if there's a
black swan event that's one thing where
something really bad happens but i mean
a slow like a decline i could see would
be like the u.s is like just becomes
like
you know there's always gonna be listen
you drop me my belief at least you drop
me into the sahara desert
and i will figure out a way to become
rich in the sahara desert
okay like there's always gonna be
wealthy people and entrepreneurs and the
one thing the u.s has is entrepreneurial
spirit ingenuity
so you'll always have successful people
what happens is the middle class gets
squeezed
and it gets harder people have to work
harder they have to less
um you know the the lower class
just struggles more and you have the and
also what you have with globalism too is
a concentration of wealth in the hands
of a few people that's what you see with
like the bezos of the world
i don't put elon musk into that category
at all i love you i think elon musk was
just like he's just a he's like got the
elon musk cool dude
net worth thing going on like he's not
monopolizing anything at all but he's
just like it's hysterical like but other
than elon
you look at these guys that have you
know like bezos and and facebook these
are glo these are globalist
people that have made money on globalism
and
because that's what you know globalism
concentrates wealth in
in the few people's hands that's my
opinion and it's
very bad for most people other than them
did you see this thing just in the last
couple weeks that bill gates
is now the largest farm owner in the
united states yeah isn't that crazy it's
like what does he know that that we
don't
or maybe we do know it we just can't
bill bill gates has always
always very quietly been in things like
food security
water security that's been a big play
for bill gates quietly for many many
years
um so that didn't surprise me when i saw
that he's always been talking about that
stuff
it's just that he's been overshadowed in
the last few years about his you know
vaccinations and stuff like that
um but you know listen
there's two sides here to bill gates
either he's
a really benevolent amazing brilliant
genius or he is the most evil man in the
world like
there's people that like it's like it's
like i kind of like
i i either like i don't know like if
bill gates heart is pure that
i'm saying he's a what a great guy he
really what a wonderful guy or
but boy he's dr evil like you know i
don't know i mean like
i guess the jury's out like i kind of
like you know you know my ex-wife
really hates him just hate like she
thinks he's real you know and like i
always say well i don't know like
i think like what has he really done
like that's so bad like i don't know
like but like you know she's like you
don't know you don't know
you know you don't know maybe she's
right i i don't know like i don't know
but
it's certainly he's not gonna end up
going down history as a guy who was like
oh yeah he's interesting at all this guy
is gonna be like what an amazing
benevolent amazing guy oh like dr
freaking evil you know
yeah this this goes one of two ways i
have to back up for a second because i
don't have any great drug stories like
you know being on quaaludes and having
to drag myself down the stairs into the
lamborghini anything like that
but the one good drug story i have is
that
in 1997 in the summer i ate a bunch of
pop brownies with some friends
and we went to the movie theater we're
basically tripping like we were just
like truly like when it got you at that
level like out of our mind
we were going to see air force one on
opening night and it was sold out
the only other movie we could go into
you'll see why i'm telling you this
story
was contact which i had not heard of
contact
and i sat down and i'm tripping i mean
i'm full on like losing my [ __ ]
and that opening panorama scene of the
universe that i'm sure you know that two
minute just extended
and that thing blew my mind and it truly
it changed my life i read all of carl
sagan's books after that you know
contact
was his only uh nonfiction but i read
all of his
movie all of his books and it changed my
life it opened me
to all of that stuff i thought i thought
you would appreciate that i know it's
not as exciting as some of your drug
uh adventures well good good pot brownie
story's always good cause like it's one
of those weird
things that like you know like you're
like uh-oh like i think i
ate too much oh yeah yeah it's an uh-oh
moment and you can't shut it off you're
like oh my god you know
we've all had those yeah um
what's next for you with all this in
mind all this opportunity and all the
stuff you're doing
i'm i'm feeling like that i'm really
like on
path right now like i think i'm like i
kind of love what i'm doing
um i love my the business that i'm in
right now
and um i'm
slowly but surely like just like
you know like what i'm doing is i'm
building a network really
of for recruiting and you know going
city by city
and ultimately then you know state by
state country by country and really
trying to
create a platform that will allow
anybody who wants to go into sales to
really easily get themselves trained
and get a high-paying job and also allow
companies that are looking for sales
people
quality sales people to be able to go
somewhere and use this as a resource to
instantly be able to
find you know the type of people they
want to know what their level of
training is
how they perform on certain types of
tests and scores i think this doesn't
exist right now
with sales because like you know for
most professions you know you could look
at someone's resume or
their career or their school and say oh
this person went to harvard or yale or
this place or that place and
you know they've got this degree so
they've done the work and that doesn't
hold up when it comes to sales like you
know
some of the worst sales people in the
world went to the best schools and vice
versa people that did not even
graduate high school or incredible sales
people and
huge assets to companies so there's a
different parameter so i think it's a
very
disjointed uh kind of screwed up model
that how companies go about
choosing sales people and trying to
scale and it's probably their biggest
pain point so a company that's trying to
grow
they'll typically say the biggest
painful is you know my turnover of
salespeople was massive
first year attrition is enormous first
year performance is terrible
so i'm trying to address that problem by
you know really
you know creating a much uh more robust
database
and data set for people to go out there
and choose
sales people so let's say it's a
long-term project i have right now it's
like mapping the genome
it's like a little shorter than that but
i'm doing that right now it's going
amazing and i'm doing a lot of
consulting right now for companies
exciting stuff
and i'm waiting anxiously for
the world to open and this is going to
be just a wonderful year for me of just
going country to country to country to
country
for all of those countries that i you
know always go to every i mean i just
could have a
fun couple of years where i'll get to
really travel the world and really uh
do what i love doing which is you know
getting in for the large crowd so
in the meantime i'm just doing that and
um and having a lot of fun
jordan i owe you dinner we're doing it
at my place next week i'm gonna text you
in a minute we'll get it on the book
and we'll do it all right and it was
great talking to you
and uh wait where are we sending where
are we sending people where are we
sending people
i want to put a link in the description
belford.com or straightlinehiring.com
check it out and uh everyone knows where
to find me i'm
i'm a weed i'm everywhere all right good
seeing you man
take care phil bye if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about lifestyles instead of non-stop
yelling check out our
lifestyle playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics check out our full episode
playlist
they're both right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe
and click the notification bell